job openings rise unexpectedly to 10.7
million in September despite Fair hikes
uh despite fed hikes so let's look at
this here uh job openings Rose
unexpected only September suggesting
that the American labor market is not
cooling as fast as inflation Fighters at
the Federal Reserve hope employers post
a 10.7 million job vacancies in
September up from an upwardly of 10.3
million jobs in August the labor
department said Tuesday economists had
expected the number of job openings to
drop below 10 million for the first time
since June of 2021 another sign that the
labor market remains tight and employers
are unwilling to let workers go layoffs
dropped in September to 1.3 million the
fewest since April but the number of
people quitting their jobs slipped in
September to just below 4.1 million
still high by historical historical
standard uh Tom what does this mean to
us well I got up way too early had way
too much coffee and I saw that and I'm
like wait a minute what's behind the
numbers what's in this 10.7 so I went to
the United States Bureau of Labor
Statistics and I printed out the report
that was there and I said there's a
handy report here with column headings
and everything and I said first of all
where are these jobs and I just thought
it was kind of interesting
the 10.7 million jobs 4.2 million of
them are open in the south
5 million is the Midwest and West and
there's only 1.7 million open in the
Northeast and that's actually down so
behind the 10.7 there are jobs open in
the south
level in the west and Midwest then down
in the Northeast okay that's very
interesting so they're following the sun
toward the winter but where are these
jobs well I saw a couple headlines this
week Apple freezes hiring I think we all
saw that nothing to see here they're
just saying hey we're on a hiring freeze
we've also seen a couple other tech
companies Silicon Valley and large
companies saying hiring freezes now
those are skilled workers white collar
workers and also I found um a couple
little bit things on Venture funded
companies like uh one that stuck out was
gem which is Zen source which is uh has
170 million dollars of venture
investment they just laid off one third
of their Workforce and they are a white
collar competitor to zip recruiter and
others well that's interesting so then I
said huh
I delve into the numbers check this out
of the 10.7 million 1.6 million of those
jobs are in Leisure and Hospitality in
other words restaurants hotels Food
Service
2.1 million are in social assistance
Health Care you know what that is that's
retirement community nursing hospice
things like that
so wow then
I said well how many are white collar
workers only 1.9 million so of the 10.7
only 1.9 million are white-collar or
skilled work
so that lines up with apple saying well
we're freezing and then another one
stuck out this one's up
um to almost 1.7 from 1.5 over two
months
where wholesale transportation and
warehousing is up now why would that be
because we're going in the fourth
quarter baby and those are Amazon jobs
oh wow and those are in the new drop
ship economy we've got it's not just
Amazon it's up there so it was very
interesting to me and the government
still had a million of them out there so
there's a million jobs for the
government so what's really interesting
to me is there's two sides to this
you've got Hospitality
warehousing and retirement homes and
retirement communities accounting for
almost six million of the jobs and you
only have two million White Collar this
is called a barbell where you have two
ends of the barbell you know what I mean
and it's skinny in the middle so the
jobs that are being created are not high
paying high skill jobs that's what's
behind these numbers by the way so let
me tell you they like to talk about 10.7
because it's an election yeah but but
here's the problem though here's the
problem though so look look at the way
the article reads the article reads and
says the following it says uh what page
so look but look listen to the way the
article reads New York says U.S job
openings Rose unexpectedly in September
suggesting that the American labor
market is not cool and as fast as the
inflation Fighters at Federal Reserve
hoped one more time uh suggesting the
American labor market is not cooling
meaning the Federal Reserve wants the
American labor market to cool off so if
this number is true guess what it means
for December what interest rate with
rate hikes you're going to get another
three quarters of a basis point because
it's not cool enough as weird as this
sounds this needs to cool off more for
them to get to only half or a quarter
but if you're getting numbers like this
Powell's sitting there saying nope it's
not working yet maybe one more month
maybe one more month so I'm I'm leaning
towards three quarters of a basis point
in December uh half to three quarters of
a basis point I don't think it's going
to go to a quarter he said they're going
to do half I think maybe three quarters
of basis point if these numbers are not
turned I'm with you 100 and I take this
back to our economic discussion on
mortgages there are not high paying jobs
out there to go be able to pay that
higher percent mortgage folks and so I
said if your job is moving you to
another city so if you like this you
want to watch another one click right
here
you're going to be a two-year-old
yeah no question about